such exciting night who is the biggest
influence in your life
I believe my biggest influence is that's
a good question throughout my career
there been many different stars I've
hitched my wagon to and for different
reasons you know in my early years I
love Diana Ross and The Supremes and
Cher and David Bowie and then as I got
older I didn't need that that type of
that type of starting to hitch onto
anymore
I found that strength in myself okay
great men who I mean
do you would you feel extra pressure you
know to be a role model to all of your
fans
no I feel no pressure to be a role model
you know if somebody gets something from
my experience right on but my main goal
is to enjoy and experience my own life
but if somebody gets something out of it
right on but I don't want to be
distracted by trying to do things to
influence other people am i it's my
experience and let's start there we have
to ask you season 9 who is the biggest
threat this season well they all are
these are kids who grew up watching our
show so they know how to play the game
they come with their their catchphrases
they come with a strategy but we try to
know we always foil their plans so
they're all threats okay who would you
say is the most memorable or it stands
out the most this season that would be
me yeah yeah every season I witty much
win every season
[Music]